so uh this is the moment you've all been
waiting for whether you know it or not
if you've been watching my channel for
any length period of time
this is the moment you've been waiting
for this is called
markiplier makes excuses
now in my
[Laughter]
deep inhale
in my time on youtube i've made a few
problems
just on youtube or in life in general
mutant life babe i don't know i'm not
held accountable for that because
there's no video evidence right
but in my time on youtube i have made
a few promises that maybe
i didn't quite meet the expectations of
the people that were expecting that to
be so
my good friends here are
going to test me they're going to
confront me with various situations
where i may
or may not have maybe broken a promise
here or there
so if the excuse isn't good enough we've
got a big ol
ice bucket here
and every
just a little handful
a joke's on you you've now weakened me
up to it now i'm gonna be used to it
when i get dumped
okay so i'm hoping that spider i washed
down isn't gonna crawl back up here but
this is how it's gonna work
ethan has a big old list of promises
that i've made he's going to confront me
with it i'm going to make an excuse and
then you
chat are going to say whether it's a
good excuse or a bad excuse
if it's a bad excuse i get dunked on but
me i'm very charismatic and i'm good
with words
so i'm thinking that i'll convince you
that it's a good excuse every time
i've got the first one all right get
ready to use your words big boy
this has been a reoccurring theme that
you've brought up on your channel
multiple times
about being more consistent with update
vlogs
specifically updates specifically update
vlogs about
both the channel and you ah
well the thing is
see update vlogs there
there's a specific time and place that
is required
i haven't done it regularly i admit i
haven't done it regularly
but i have updated whenever there is an
important
life event that occurs in my life i have
updated
that hundred dollars no no no
no no
keep going hey update
whenever there is a necessary moment
to do so and
and it wouldn't behoove me to update
without good reason to update
so i i have in fact updated when need be
uh good excuse he does important updates
good good
not good enough bad excuse bad bad no
bad bad tyler duncan bad bad bad no no
bad excuse that's a good excuse
hundred dollars don't come again let
them have it
little on the top on the top good
mark speaking of consistency
do you remember like one or two months
ago you said that you were gonna
eat a ghost pepper every time you uh
missed an upload
what happened what happened with that
because i'm pretty sure you've missed an
upload
since the last pepper listen okay that
coincided with the exact moment that i
had to sign
38 000 calendars i was going to miss
it was either i was going to sign them
all or was going to miss i ate two in a
row
fine fight you made a markiplier promise
do you know what that is do you want me
to tell you what a markiplier
oh my gosh because whenever markiplier
makes a promise
he always says no matter what i want
that's another 100 something again
he always says that no matter what if i
miss an upload i'll have to eat this
ghost pepper
am i telling the truth okay hang on hang
on hang on that
you you are correct oh my word is my
bond but
i knew i mathed it out exactly how many
days i met i was already signing for two
days
but eating a ghost pepper every day is
very damaging to the stomach line and i
knew that i was gonna have eight days of
signing
therefore it was either i eat a ghost
pepper every day
and then i sit in that factory going to
the bathroom every two hours
or i don't eat ghost peppers do the
healthy choice
and just say that i'm a bad bad man who
doesn't fulfill his promises which is i
did
in an update vlog i said that i said
that i'm screwed for life and that
i did that i personally think because it
was health related i consider it a good
excuse all right
the chat is saying a lot of good excuses
so you get away for now okay
what happened to learning german mark
you said that you were going to learn
german that was a new year's resolution
that it was
that was a promise okay
i my main reason for learning german was
because i wanted to connect with my
roots
but i switched from german to korean
because that was more in tune with my
family of whom i actually have in korea
and then i did keep up with my korean
studies
because i went to korea and i was able
to talk in korean
to my family okay but where's the german
okay no no the german
okay i admit i did i did stop learning
german
that is so bad excuse chad that is a
fact that is a fact i did stop learning
jerk but
i i think maybe i went at the beginning
of the year i might have said that i
wanted to learn a language
maybe and not just german you were
pretty specific about this i mean
i mean i on a technicality he
technically did
learn some german i mean that's kind of
[ __ ]
when you say i want to learn german it's
not i want to learn
words it's like i want to learn a good
excuse though yeah everyone is saying
yes okay and i did keep up with the
korean you did
see see now mark i remember something
very specifically
uh i moved to la a little over two years
ago
uh and when i uh came out to la
i uh i asked you because you
you keep talking about it a lot uh when
you were gonna move back to cincinnati
and i remember that this is when bob and
wade were in town
and back then uh this was right when i
first came out to la too
you said in two years i want to go back
to
cincinnati hundred dollars
you said in two years
i'll be back in cincinnati for sure
what happened with that um
listen this is important listen listen
closely
to my words look at my eyes when i speak
and he's stalling
i don't
like la first and foremost
i love cincinnati and i wish i could be
closer to all my friends
[Music]
hmm wish you wish you work
for yourself there's really no uh reason
why why you can't move back there okay
how many meetings do you have that you
have to have in person here in l.a
okay not very many okay um
i can see that it may seem on the
surface
that i um very
very bad but i haven't made the
experience i haven't made the excuse
yeah i haven't made these
i haven't made it wait no if um wade
wade lives in cincinnati and i don't
want to be near wade
baddie wade's good guy at heart
all right mark this next one comes from
the chat yeah
yeah you know you you're a big community
guy you really love your community a lot
you do a lot to engage with your
community
but there was one thing in particular
that you said that you really wanted to
do
regularly uh something that you haven't
done
in fact since i moved here i believe
reading your comments
what happened with that one okay well
catch 22 i have done them since you got
back because i did them in that
apartment that i was living in
you remember i do amy did my makeup in
the night oh that is
i just can't stand copying people on
youtube
i can't do it i'm an original content
kind of guy i always do everything
original
this is an ice bucket challenge in a
bathroom
everyone does everyone does
reading your comments and i felt
like i needed to innovate on
i would say that's bad because you've
given different excuses in the past
that doesn't mean that they're all bad
say you didn't like the way that it
shifted the comments
that that that's that's a good that's a
good reason that's a good reason
that's a good result
all right i guess
duncan
[Music]
all right mark just for you your dear
dear beloved dog
chica what in every way
i remember this very vividly because i
stumbled
upon your first chica video the other
day and i watched it
and you said something in the video what
you said that you were going to take
chica out for walks three times a day
for
big big walks and you're going to take
her out every day for big play times
and take them out big walks get those
morning poops in
now i'd like to say that i know you
pretty well
and i did know your schedule very well
for a while
what happened with those big walks every
day
all right listen listen now i know what
you're about to say
because you said that you were going to
take her on big big walks
if somebody else takes her on big big
walks that is not
valid no no no okay
here's here's the t right for the past
year original youtuber you can't be
original and say
for the past year and a half for the
past year and a half
i have walked chica three times a day
amy can confirm this
i have i i want to ask chica ask chica
too now that being said
maybe maybe
he says he does maybe in the
first year and a half of having her
i may have narrowed it down
to no once a day
ah and you know when the most important
time to have those boxes
is in the beginning when you have to
bond with your new dog
joking on your own
[Music]
i lived on a hill
mark you're a very fit man we can all
see that hills should be no trouble for
you
you don't know how to respond bad bad he
still did it bad
very bad very very bad
speaking of being an original youtuber
you do
these dramatic laugh challenges
and you always say in the very beginning
that on the very first video
you will not laugh
that doesn't happen can you explain
why you lie to people saying that you
will not laugh and then you let out a
giggle
and this is in multiple videos not just
one i
have the best of intentions with every
word that i say on the internet
does that mean that circumstances
outside of my control
can sometimes lead me to maybe chortle
at things that may not might not have
been
i thought i would choreograph
that's a 99.99 there's a hundred oh yeah
we're going on this side
let's bounce you out a little bit
there's another one it was a 99
i want to be honest because i'm an
honest pun
all right mark
so this next one you really what i
didn't finish
but i didn't finish no okay so there's
still a chance for another dunk
no because i'm about to blow your mind
with the truth is that another promise
you're willing to make
i don't know where this came from
another 100 god
feels nice very chilly
i'm about to blow your ass out of here
with the truth let's hear it another 100
give it to you
where's the money
it's called try not to laugh there's no
guarantee from the title i
wrote the title i said from the get-go
pre-empting
my any words nice it's try and i said i
try and then
i tried i tried super hard
challenge mind blown right good
it's a good excuse good excuse all right
we'll give it to him
[Applause]
another one
[Music]
oh
what do you have to say for yourself
warm yourself up and stretch out you
know
my word is my bone
what
listen it's fine i am i
am a man i try
very hard to live up to the expectations
that i put for myself
and then some people also put
expectations upon me and maybe i say a
word or two without outline of the
the truth of the matter but but big but
i still i don't know where i'm going
with this
all right we'll give it to you okay all
right now this next one you really like
to pawn this off
on tyler and i oh there are a few
punishments that you haven't had and you
always say that that's our fault
but is it really i don't think so
especially consider we find out through
the fans and not you
and also katherine
has created punishments in the past
and you have said no
you have said that you didn't have the
time to do it or you had
something else in mind so there was a
punishment
and you vetoed it which i think
should be against the rules it's a
blatant strike
against his own promise this is true
i designed a whole charity stream and
then like the day before you're like
actually i think i'm gonna do a solo
stream for today and bring guests in
um uh i uh i know for a fact
many things and uh one of them is that
i when being punished
i think that it should come from a place
where i don't suspect it
and if people are telling it to me for
my approval then that's not
my fault that they came to me with a yes
or no proposition in the first place
a punishment should be a situation
that's constrained
where i don't even know what's happening
[Music]
oh yes where was i uh in a bathtub
about to get dunked twice because i
still have two banks
okay um i'm gonna save them do you give
me a nice surprise dunk every once in a
while
i um uh i made my case
i think i made you i made my case i
played the fifth
um i chad what do you say
um we can leave that one alone because
it could be
you know tyler and i didn't do it up to
your par or whatever
you play video games i do i do i do i do
now there's a video game
that uh you said you would finish that
you never did
do you know what that game is there's a
few that spring to mind
i'll bring up the first one well the
first one is
criminal origins back in 2012 when i
started playing and i got to episode 13
but then my computer crashed and i lost
the save file and i didn't feel like
going back
okay and then skyrim i didn't finish
that i was like two missions away from
the very end of it i didn't finish that
either
and then there was one shot which i i
didn't finish well i mean i finished it
but then there was another ending that
was added in dlc and then i said i'd get
back to it but then i don't have the
save file for that either
i'm not the one i'm talking about i'm
referring to uh
spanish i'd be [ __ ]
are you dead are you i beat bandit
just because people say i didn't be
banished doesn't mean that i didn't be
banished i beat vanish
okay i vouched for you i already had you
on that one
keep doing that so your hair jiggles it
looks funny
[Music]
now this one the community doesn't
really know about but
um when i moved to la we lived in a
certain place
you really wanted to move to a different
place uh you wanted to move to a
different place because
a lot of other youtubers live in this
place and
a lot of us were very like ooh i don't
know if it would be worth it to move
and you said that one of the biggest
things
would be we would be collaborating with
other youtubers
all the time how many people
when we all lived in that area do you
think we collaborated with
you cannot say that big
dark video because that was during
vidcon
i would also like to say that
when you lived in an apartment you lived
literally across the hall from another
big youtuber
all right hear me out on this one
i am an introvert
and i sometimes overtake the preference
of working
sometimes i eat maybe
more than sometimes almost every time
take
the preference of working by myself
sometimes
and i just you know it's hard to it's
got to
reach out to people sometimes i don't
know i don't have their numbers or
anything
i would like to say something you're one
of the biggest creators on the platform
it is not hard for you to reach out to
other youtubers he even admitted
at vidcon he was surprised at how easy
it was to get them to come do the
video there are i think a
very few people that would pass up an
opportunity to work with you
all right you got me by the short hairs
on that one
um
oh bad excuse bad
let's get to one that will really plead
please bottom line the steins
i don't even have to explain it what
happened with that do they even have
their signs yet i i believe the prom
yes they do but they they do but i will
say mark didn't do it
all right that one i just straight up
was too lazy to send it
that's not a bad excuse that is a bad
experience
you were lazy no
because you admit it doesn't mean that
it's a shitty excuse you're
just being amazing all right so
because you still have three more and
because you've been in here for a while
i think we'll get to the very last one
okay
which is possibly the biggest of the
lies that you've told why
sorry promises that you've broken since
tyler and i moved out here
and since the last time you did it you
said
that the three of us were gonna film a
pole dancing video
for over two years you said that this
video was coming
and then you top it all off you betrayed
us
and made a pole dancing video with sean
instead
to promote your hidden and plain sight
brand
and this wasn't one promise this was at
least four or five because
there was the two times at least on tour
where he's like oh and tyler's knees
better
straight away we're going to do it my
knee was better
we talked about it didn't happen there
were many many sets
again there were even times when
i was talking in the office you would
say we'll film that next week
never happened i bought bowls
my ceilings were too tall
now when you filmed
all the other pole dancing videos when
you filmed the one with sean recently
was that in your home i thought that was
uh in a dance studio
it didn't seem too hard to get to a
dance studio all those other times huh
man you know
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm a bad friend sometimes ah cramp
ah leg cramp but
i try my best
i don't know if that's trying your best
buckle
but we will [ __ ] you then
[Music]
now i'm out we have the excuse i'm
waiting
i am
oh wait i want to get this up close
i want them to see the lies in your eyes
i have no
excuse i
fail at my ambitious goals and even the
most trivial things sometimes
and that's no good to anybody especially
my friends
it's not a good thing to do and i'm
sorry
have to finish the bot
finish him
what are you gonna keep next time i'm
gonna
keep my promises
oh